BRIAN SINGER: Thanks
everyone for joining us.
I know it's late in the day.
Getting a little tired.
But I think we've got some
really exciting things
to show you today
about what we're
doing with partners to get their
technology in front of you.
Reduce friction.
Right?
And get you more
productive with the things
that you're building
on top of Google Cloud.
So my name is Brian Singer.
I'm also joined by Anil Dhawan.
We're both product
managers with Google Cloud.
And the reason we
called the session,
"Standing on the
Shoulders of Giants,"
is because we're out there
seeing our technology partners
and our go-to-market partners
building some really incredible
things on top of GCP.
And on top of G Suite.
And we want to make it
easier for customers
to get their hands on those
incredible technologies.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about a couple of offerings
that we have that
make it easier for you
to get partner technology.
To purchase partner technology.
And to use it in the
workloads that you're building
on top of Google Cloud.
So, hopefully, I
don't need to tell you
that ISVs provide
tremendous value, in terms
of getting you more
productive in the workloads
that you're building.
We'll go through a
couple of examples
where ISVs can help you
build more secure, more
reliable workloads.
They can help you improve
your architectures overall.
There's a tremendous amount
of expertise in our technology
partners, and we want you
to be able to leverage
that expertise, right?
It's a great multiplier
to what you're doing,
and to what we're
doing with you.
We often see customers who
have key requirements, right?
And maybe Google hasn't built
that piece of technology,
or maybe it's not something
we're going to build, right?
And our ISVs are solving those
requirements for customers
today, but you to be
able to find them.
You need to be able to know
how you can purchase and deploy
those.
In a way that really
works with what
you're doing on Google Cloud.
You also want to build
optimized workloads, obviously.
So you want architectures
that are optimized.
They're going to minimize costs.
Going to minimize
the amount of time
that your engineers have to
spend solving security risk,
DevOps issues, and so on.
Right?
And our IC partners
are so good at building
those sorts of technologies
for you to leverage.
And then finally, a
lot of you, obviously,
are migrating from
on-premise to the cloud.
It's no secret.
And often working with
these ISV partners
in your on-premise data centers.
And we want to make
it easier for you
to leverage those technologies
in the cloud, right?
With as minimal
effort as possible.
It should not be a lot of
work to migrate to the cloud.
And by using things like Test
Drives and Cloud Launcher,
you can migrate with a
minimal amount of risk
with tried and
tested architectures.
So really to sum it up, right?
Partners help you
get to where you
want to go faster, with less
risk, and better outcomes,
right?
And that's really
what we're trying
to drive at the
end of the day is
ROI and better outcomes for your
companies and your technology.
So let's talk a
little bit about how
you might think about building
a solution on top of GCP.
And how a partner might
assist you with that.
So pretty common thing that
folks use the cloud to do
is build a
public-facing website.
Right?
And this sort of
architecture is no secret.
You have instances.
They're serving requests through
some sort of a load balancer.
But very soon, after
you build a website--
typically, if you're building a
website that people know about.
Right?
You're going to have some
security concerns, right?
You have to secure your data.
You have to secure
your workload.
So you start to think
about how can I actually
go about doing this, right?
And well, we're at
a Google conference,
so obviously the first
thing you're going to do
is start Googling.
How do I secure my application?
How do I secure
it against attack?
How do I secure it against DDOS.
And you're probably going to
end up reading a few blogs,
finding a few solutions, right?
Getting some advice
that's out there.
But what we found is that
at the end of the day,
often, a partner
technology and ISV solution
is going to be the
fastest and best option
for you to solve a particular
issue you might have.
So how do you go about
finding the right solution?
And figuring out if it's
going to work for you?
Well, if you're like me, the
first thing you're going to do
is see what's out there
and evaluate it, right?
You're going to see,
how does this work?
What features does it have?
Does it run quickly?
Right?
And in the evaluation, right?
You're probably narrow it
down to a few solutions
that you're looking at.
And then you're going
to start testing them.
You're going to start testing
them with your own workloads,
with your own data, in your
own environments, right?
And then finally,
after you've tested it
and you've selected
a particular vendor,
you want to get to production.
Now, we all know that going
from the evaluation of the test
to the production
phase with an ISV
probably involves some
sort of negotiation
over pricing and
procurement, et cetera.
Right?
That's all friction, in
terms of building out
your particular workload, right?
And as developers
or IT managers,
we want to minimize that.
The promise of the
Cloud is that we're
going to minimize
that friction, right?
And at Google, we want to
help you do that as well.
So we see most of our
customers going on this path,
when they're looking at
purchasing partner solutions.
There's the initial discovery.
What solutions are
out there that can
solve my particular problem?
Right?
And that's where it's
incredibly valuable
to go take a Test Drive.
We'll talk a little
bit more about what
Test Drives are, but they
really solve that problem of--
I need to see what's out there.
And what it does
at a high level.
I don't want to
make a commitment.
I probably don't even
want to get a phone call
from a vendor at that point.
I don't want to
have to integrate
with my own toolchain.
I don't want to have
to start calling up
development managers.
I just want to see what's out
there and see how it works.
Right?
And I probably don't
have a ton of expertise
with these solutions either.
The next step-- you've
probably narrowed it down.
You have some solutions that
might meet your requirements.
You want to run a proof
of concept, right?
And you want to do that
at as low of a cost,
and some medium amount of
commitment as possible, right?
You want to see how it works
with your particular workload--
that solution.
How it runs on your
particular data, right?
What sort of results you get?
How fast it is?
Et cetera.
There's some
toolchain that might
be required, some sort of
minimal effort to stand it up.
And you're starting to build
a little bit of expertise
on the solution.
Maybe at that point,
you're actually
working with the vendor to
find an architecture that's
going to work for you.
And then finally, hopefully,
you select a solution,
and you want to go to a
production deployment.
Right?
And at that point, you
want it to be simple,
but it's also got to integrate
with your current tools
that you're using
for, maybe, CICD.
It's got to work in your
particular environment.
You're making a commitment at
that point to this solution.
You are investing time and
resources in configuring it.
In making it work
with your workload.
You're building it
into your toolchain,
and you're building
quite a bit of expertise.
So it's really a
journey that you're
going through for any
solution that you select.
And we're going to
show you how you
can make that journey
on Google Cloud
with as little
effort as possible.
And it's not surprising, we
hear from places like IDG.
83% of IT buyers rely on demos.
You want to see it work.
You're not going to take
a vendor at face value.
That a particular solution
does what they say it does.
Perfect.
So I talked about Test Drives
a little bit, so what are they?
Test Drives are sandbox
trial environments
provided by GCP
technology partners
that allow you to rapidly try
their solutions at absolutely
no cost to you.
You don't even
need a GCP account
to run a test drive, right?
The partner is taking on all
the cost of the infrastructure,
right?
They're building
out the environment.
And the great thing is that the
partner is pre-configuring it
with data, right?
And we'll take a look
at what that means.
But what it means is you're not
having to put a ton of effort
in this initial
evaluation phase.
You can rapidly narrow down
which solution is going
to be the best for your needs.
The great thing is that these
environments are completely
torn down upon
completion, right?
So you don't need to worry about
your data staying up there.
Or someone having
access to what you did.
And so on.
So it's a sandbox.
It runs for a preset
amount of time,
and it's torn down
upon completion.
So we actually launched Test
Drives about a month ago
for GCP.
We've seen quite
a bit of interest
from the partner
community since then.
We have several Test
Drives available now.
We have more that are
being added every week.
I encourage you to
go take a test drive.
You can do it now.
It's GCP dash, Test Drive,
dot orbitera, dotcom.
You can browse what's
available, and you
can request Test Drives
you don't see there now.
And I'd encourage
you, if there's
certain solutions you'd
like to try that you don't
see, go ahead and request it.
We're working with the
vendors to get more and more
Test Drives stood up
on a weekly basis.
So how do we do Test Drives?
Well, we use Deployment Manager.
If you're familiar with
Deployment Manager,
these are
pre-configured templates
that the ISV is creating that
we provision upon request.
Once you start the Test Drive,
and the actual Test Drive
is provisioned, the
solution's available to you
through web endpoints.
Right?
So we'll take a look at what
that actually means in a demo.
And then once it's completed,
the entire stack is torn down.
So we're actually
deleting the stack,
again using Deployment Manager.
What that means is very
low effort for you.
You can see the entire
solution being deployed.
You know that it runs.
And you know what
the architecture is.
So let's take a look at what
that actually looks like.
And Anil, if you could
just come up real quickly.
So we can flip over.
Thank you.
So we're now here at
the Test Drive landing
page, where you can see a few
of the available Test Drives.
Looker is an ISV partner that
provides a data analytics
platform.
So I'm interested
in that Test Drive.
I'm going to go here, and I'm
asked to create an account
or sign in.
So creating an account
just takes a minute, right?
Just fill out some
basic information.
And you have that
account available.
I did know that we were
going to have a demo,
so I actually already
created an account
and actually started
the Test Drive.
So we'd have something
to show you today.
So I'm going to go ahead
and sign into my account
that I've got.
All right.
And you can see now that
I've started that trial,
and that trial is
now in progress.
Right?
We have about four
hours remaining,
where I can go
and test this out.
And again, at the
end of that trial
it's going to be
completely torn down.
And you can see the URL that
this solution is available at.
And the log in and the password.
So let's go take a look at what
Looker has made available to me
in the Test Drive.
All right.
So now we're logging
in to Looker.
The great thing is-- a
lot of these ISV partners
are putting work in to
make it really easy for you
to try their solutions, right?
So Looker has actually
given you this landing page.
You have supporting
documentation.
Certain things that you can
try out in the solution.
How do I build a dashboard?
Get some basic overviews.
In addition to what's
available within Looker,
we actually have, within
the test drive environment,
videos that are available
for you to look at.
Documentation, a manual,
additional resources,
as well as a log of what
was actually deployed.
So you can actually
see these solutions
getting deployed
onto Google Cloud
as the Test Drive is happening.
So I'm going to pop back
over here into Looker,
and let's see what's available
for me in this environment.
Some dashboards.
Everybody likes dashboards.
Let's see what we can find.
And you'll see that,
as this loads--
what they've done is
they've pre-populated it
with some sample data, right?
So if you want to
see how it works,
you don't have to go
through all the effort
to hook it up to all your
different data sources, right?
You can get a quick idea of--
is this a solution that is going
to solve the particular problem
that I have?
All right.
I can see total orders
as these load up.
Sort of brand share
of wallet over time.
My top purchasers, et cetera.
All right.
And it's not Looker that's slow,
it's the network that we're on.
This loads pretty quickly.
So again, there's a
variety of solutions
that are available
today for Test Drives.
We're adding more every week.
We want to hear your feedback,
as to what kinds of solutions
you want to see.
And we're really excited about
what we can make available,
and what we can do
with these partners.
Of course, when the
Test Drive is over,
I can click the Stop button,
and the whole thing is actually
torn down at this point.
And trial is over.
And then very easy-- if you
want to have the vendor contact
you--
if you have more questions--
You can do that.
Perfect.
So can we flip back
over to the slides?
Great.
Thank you.
So we want to hear from you.
You want to see a solution in
Test Drives, go to the link.
Let us know.
Otherwise, feel free to go
try out the solutions we have.
Again, this is a program that
we launched about a month ago.
We're really excited
about it, and we
want to get it into your hands.
Perfect.
So now I'm going
to turn things over
to Anil, who's going to take
you through Cloud Launcher.
The next step in
that journey, where
you can actually go, and then
do the production deployments.
ANIL DHAWAN: Thanks Brian.
BRIAN SINGER: Thanks Anil.
ANIL DHAWAN: So as
Brian showed you,
Test Drives are a great
way to kick the tires.
You actually don't pay anything,
which is pretty brilliant.
And it's actually
quite a useful resource
to learn about new software.
I'm going to talk to you today
about Cloud Launcher, which
is our GCP marketplace.
And one of the
things we think about
is how do we accelerate your
development through the use
of ISV products.
And so if you're a developer,
what are some of the things
that you care about?
Well, if you came from the
on-prem world into Cloud,
you already know
that you can spend
a lot more time coding and less
plugging in ethernet cables.
But even though you
come into Cloud,
you're still
configuring instances.
If you're trying to create a
production level deployment,
you're still worrying
about firewall rules,
making sure that network
can talk to each other,
making sure that your SSH keys
are managed well, et cetera.
So these are still
challenges, even
though you're in the Cloud.
Although, it's much better than
being in the on-prem world.
The next is you're
often given a task.
Like hey, we're trying to
build this new website,
let's go figure out
how to build it.
And maybe your
colleague down the hall
is excited about a new language.
Like Node.
And you might be
a Rails developer,
and you might want to
get started with that.
So trying things out quickly
is a very important use-case.
And without handholding,
you can be quite lost.
This is one of those challenges
that we see with developers
today.
And so when you
do find a solution
that you're interested
it in-- maybe
that node.JS stack that you're
just starting to learn about.
While you often want
to tutorials, and you
want getting-started guides.
And you want to make sure
that your journey in using
that software is a great one.
Because, if you're like me,
I have very little patience
when it comes to configuring and
debugging software that I think
should just work.
So you want to make sure
that experience is great.
And once you've taken the
solution, you've used it,
and you like it-- you've
tweaked it the way you want--
you [? won't ?] often take that
same concept into production.
And you don't want to
have to restart everything
from scratch, all over again.
You want to be able
to do it yourself.
And you want to be
able to take all
of the configuration,
investment,
and deploy it straight
into production.
So that's great if
you're a developer.
If you're an IT
administrator, you're
supporting an organization
of developers.
If you think along
somewhat related lines,
you're thinking about
how do I standardize
the way some third party
software is deployed, right?
I don't want to have one team
in one part of my organization
running the same piece of
software in one pattern,
and another team, maybe
in a different geography,
running in a different way.
Makes it very
difficult to understand
security, versions, et cetera.
And the next is how
do I reduce cost?
And especially in
agile IT organizations,
how do I make sure my developers
are as productive as possible?
So this notion of kind
of self-service IT.
Where developers can
go, find solutions,
provision it themselves.
Without having to
bother the IT department
for every little thing.
And this plays a role
in two dimensions.
One is on the
technical side of, how
do I get infrastructure
up and running?
But an equal challenge
for a lot of organizations
is a developer wants to use some
third party piece of software,
and they now have to go
through a procurement system
or get approval from someone,
even to do a proof of concept.
And so this is
where marketplaces
like Cloud Launcher can
fill the gap quite nicely.
And so Google Cloud
Launcher is our product.
I'd say the easiest
way to get started
with products and services
on GCP from third parties.
It's integrated directly
inside of our console.
I'll show you a demo in a bit.
How many of you already
used Launcher today
or have you used it?
That's about half of you guys.
We have very sophisticated
solution configuration.
I think it's one of the
biggest differentiators we
have in our marketplace,
compared to other marketplaces
out there.
I'll speak more in a bit about
that, especially with the demo.
We have production
grade software,
so we have amazing vendors.
You've heard some of them in
the keynotes from this week.
And we're constantly
adding more solutions.
And one of the nice things about
having a central place where
you can purchase all the
software is, as a GCP customer,
you get a unified bill.
So if you're purchasing
software through the launcher,
it's showing up on
your Google bill.
So we facilitate that
relationship with the ISV.
You don't have to work
separately with them to get
the software up and running.
So let's talk about the
kinds of solutions we have.
We have hundreds and
hundreds of products today.
These are just a sampling of
some of the major vendors.
You heard about SAP
coming on board.
I think in Dan's
keynote yesterday.
All logos-- all companies
you probably recognize
are probably used today.
But in addition to those
commercial vendors,
we also have a custom program
we have at Google, called
Google Click to Deploy.
And what these are is a set of
solutions packaged by Google.
And they typically are
popular open source stacks.
And what we've done is we've
taken vanilla configurations,
and we've put them together
and pre-deploy them
in these packages.
So if you want to create
one of these instances,
instead of doing it on your own,
you can just use one of these.
And really the
spirit behind this
was our insight in
that-- the moment
you start in cloud, one of the
first activities you're doing
is trying to get a
piece of software
that you had maybe
on-prem, up and running.
And so that journey,
where you might
be trying to configure
a Mongo database,
and you need a cluster.
You have three or four nodes.
That might take you
several hours to configure,
simply because you
have to make sure
that SSH keys are managed well.
Making sure that IP addresses
are transported in config files
across each node.
Making sure you configure
the zones correctly.
And then if you want to do the
same thing in a different zone,
well, you have to repeat
the whole process.
So we find an opportunity
to simplify that.
And we have a set of
these Google Click
to Deploy packages.
They are some of our
more popular solutions.
Since they're pretty much open
source, vanilla configurations,
it's really what you
would have done yourself.
And there's just
community supported.
So you can read any blog
post on the internet
and apply those steps.
They just work fine.
So next I'm going to talk to
you about the kinds of solutions
we have in our launcher.
And so there are four types.
The first is virtual machines
running on Compute Engine.
So these are VM products
that run in your account.
They launch VM instances,
and you get billed for them.
So you pay for the
infrastructure.
We have several
commercial solutions,
where you're paying, of
course, for the infrastructure,
but also the license fee
from the commercial vendor.
But again, that relationship
is done through Google.
So you're not having to go out
of band and purchase a software
and come back and
try to deploy it.
These, of course,
run in your account.
And supports single and
multi VM's, and I'll give you
a demo of that in a bit.
Well sometimes, you have
an existing relationship
with the vendor.
Maybe you're coming
from on-prem,
or maybe you've had some
custom deal going on
with a particular company.
So in that case, we support
the BYOL model, which
is bring your own license.
And in this case, you're still
provisioning virtual machines.
You're doing it
through the launcher.
So the configuration
is all done for you.
You're getting a single
bill, but the bill
is only covering your
infrastructure cost.
The over the top or
license fee or usage
is done separately
through the vendor.
But you're still able to
get the benefits of Cloud
Launcher in sophisticated
deployments,
easy configuration, et cetera.
And these support, of
course, single and multi
VM configurations.
So that covers
Compute Engine VM's.
Next is SaaS.
So software as a service--
so I'm thinking about
services like sun grid.
If you wanted to send email, you
can come in through launcher,
look at the sun grid
solution, pick a plan,
and get a unified
built through Google.
So we'll hook you up
with the API keys,
we'll connect you to
all the documentation
you need to get
started-- including
the SDK's for various languages
that you might want to use.
But that bill is on
your Google bill.
OK.
So you don't have to have a
separate-again relationship
with the vendor in this case.
And last but not least,
we have a variant of SaaS.
Where we have curated a set
of vendors that we think
work well with GCP in general.
But what we have is a
listing-only solution.
So we provide the ability
to discover these vendors.
But to actually
purchase the solution,
you actually work
directly with the vendor.
So we're not stopping short
at just infrastructure that
runs on Google, we're actually
connecting you to third parties
that we think work well
with GCP in general.
In this case, you're not going
to get an integrated bill
from Google.
It's going to be independently
billed from that vendor.
And you can consume those
resources as you desire.
So what is Launcher good for?
We definitely see a lot of
folks starting with prototyping.
It's probably the fastest
way to get started.
Prototyping any new project,
any new solution, or as Brian
was showing, just
trying out new software.
So the popular
open source stacks.
One of the questions
we get is, hey,
if was going to use the open
source piece of software,
I see the same
thing in Launcher,
why would I use it in Launcher?
Why wouldn't I just do
it the way I did before?
Well there are several
benefits, and I'll walk you
through some of the demos.
First is the easiest way to
actually deploy that software.
We've taken care of
all the configuration.
We try our best to make
sure it's secure by default.
And any of the options that
you might want to tweak,
we've actually
put in our wizard.
Like UI, instead of having
to muck around with Config
files and V documentation.
So as part of that, when
we onboard each vendor,
we actually review the settings
that are there by default.
And we work with the
vendors to suggest
what are the kinds
of options, given
different types of
workloads, that a user might
want to configure?
And all of these show up in a
UI, which I'll demo in a bit.
Next we're not just stopping at
getting the infrastructure up
and running.
We understand that, great, once
you have it up and running,
you want to understand
how to use it.
So we make sure that
we have tutorials,
getting started
guides, et cetera.
All in a curated place.
So you have a one-stop
shop for everything.
So really it's a low
risk way to try software.
And my favorite point
is you can actually
apply your free trial credits.
How cool is that?
And a note on this, isn't
just for the infrastructure.
So if you sign up for
Google Cloud Platform,
we give you about $300
in free trial credits.
And you can actually apply that
$300 even to commercial license
software via the launcher.
And so it's not just
the infrastructure,
so you can actually use it
to apply for production grid
solutions.
So speaking of production
grid solutions,
Launcher's solutions
are also fantastic here.
We have multi VM and
enterprise grade solutions.
We saw with the logos before.
We have to the BYOL solution.
So if you have
customer agreements
that you're running
in production,
you can run that
same software here.
We integrate with support by
having a single pane of glass,
where you can connect
directly with the ISV
and contact their support.
So you're not fishing
around for who do I contact.
If something goes wrong.
And one of the big
benefits you get,
especially with
running open source is,
by running into the Launcher
or deploying Launcher-based
solutions, is any time there is
a new version of that solution
available--
or God forbid
there is a security
vulnerability in
that solution, we
work directly with the vendors.
Where they let us know about
a change or a vulnerability,
and we push out notifications
to all of our customers
who have deployed that
product via the launcher.
And it's a simple,
free, easy benefit
you get from deploying
the same piece of software
that you may have
configured yourself.
But just by deploying
it through Launcher,
you're getting some of these
great ancillary benefits.
Case in point, we send
hundreds of emails every year.
Most recently, for some of
the popular vulnerabilities
around MongoDB
authorization for example.
So really great benefit.
It kind of goes
unnoticed sometimes.
But if you deploy
the Cloud Launcher,
it's just one of those
things you get for free.
The next, in terms of
running in production,
is our integration with
Deployment Manager.
Brian mentioned
Deployment Manager before,
and if you are not familiar
with Deployment Manager already,
it's a Cloud service
that allows you
to describe your infrastructure
in a template or a document,
in a particular syntax.
Shown here's as an example.
And it's a set of tools
integrated in the command
line, the UI, as
well as API's that
allow you to provision that
infrastructure that you've
described in this
declarative document.
It's a really popular tool
used in CI/CD pipelines
or any production
grade deployments.
And one of the things we've
done in Cloud Launcher
is all of our package software,
virtual machine solutions--
They are all built on
Deployment Manager.
And so why do you care, and
what does that even mean?
Well, what it allows
you to do is get up
and running quickly from the
UI to deploy the software.
But once it's deployed,
you can actually
use Deployment
Manager to then tweak
the settings and
configuration and actually
integrate that same solution
into your automation or CICD
pipelines.
So it's not just about
kicking the tires.
It's actually about letting you
run the solution in production
at scale and not having
to adapt your workflows.
We can plug right in, because
Deployment Manager uses G Cloud
and supports an API.
And so you can deploy directly
and even tear down directly
from the command line.
I'm going to show you some
examples in just a moment.
So why don't we get started?
So if you can switch
over to the demo machine.
So let's start here.
So I'm logged into our Google
Cloud Platform console.
And you might be
wondering, well,
how do we even get to Launcher?
Well, there are
a couple of ways.
The first, more obvious one,
is right through the menu.
Just a few clicks away, you get
to the Launcher store front.
And let's go shopping.
So this is our store front.
You can browse a huge
catalog of solutions.
We've organized them by
what we call shelves.
So we have various categories
like virtual machines,
services, OS's,
databases, et cetera.
And we have hundreds
of solutions.
So filtering is really key.
So if you're only looking for
a particular type of solution,
you can just drill in here.
If you're looking, for
example, networking solutions,
you can see all of
them listed here.
We also support robust search.
And if you're looking for
Send an email, for example,
and you want to see Sun Grid,
you can discover it here.
We're also-- many of
you may not know this.
But we're also
integrated directly
into the Cloud
consoles' search bar.
So the unified search bar.
So let's say you were
building some project,
and you are looking
to secure it.
And you need a firewall.
Well, you just type firewall.
And you not only see, of
course, the GCP sections
like networking and
the firewall rules,
but we actually
connect you directly
to firewall-based
solutions in the Launcher.
So just another entry
point to help connect you
to those solutions.
So let's take a look
at what it looks
like to actually deploy one
of these pieces of software.
I'm going to choose WordPress,
a really popular blog.
And we're going to choose the
[? spin ?] [? army ?] version.
I want to highlight
a few key things
that we've done in
Launcher to make sure
that it's really easy
and convenient to deploy
the software.
So the first is--
this is the details page.
Giving you an overview
of the product.
Telling you about the vendor,
who you may or may not
know about from before.
We also give you a lot
of detail about the type
of software it is.
The version number, et cetera.
And for most of our
package software,
we actually list
out the contents.
So we actually tell you the
version number of dependencies,
and things that are in there.
One of the most important things
you might be thinking about
is price.
How much does a solution cost?
So we give you the breakdown.
And we also tell you about
the sustained use discount,
and we factor that right in.
So you're not left
having to recompute
and telling your IT
organization how much something
is going to cost.
We give you a pretty
accurate estimate right
on the details page.
Next, even before you
deploy the software,
we hook you up with tutorials,
documentation, support.
And if you want to learn
about the different licenses
or terms of service--
if you need to get that
approved in your organization.
We list those out
here explicitly.
So great, so you're
going through a journey.
You come across a solution.
You're saying, OK, great,
I want to give it a shot.
So you click Launch
and Compute Engine.
And this is our curated
experience that we have.
It's a wizard-like
flow that allows
you to set really
high level options,
and let us take care of
the actual deployment.
So what are some of those
options you can set here?
Well, you might want
to change the zone.
You might be interested
in deploying WordPress
in a particular region or zone.
If you're familiar with
custom machine types,
you might be interested in
customizing the actual shape
of this machine.
So again, we have smart presets.
So most blogs not
seeing a lot of traffic.
So we start off with a
pretty basic configuration.
But if we knew that this blog
was going to be pretty beefy,
we might want to bump
this up to, let's say,
a four CPU machine.
And if we knew that
were going to be
more CPU bound
than memory bound,
we might bump this lower.
And what you'll notice
on the side here
is as I'm changing
these parameters,
we're updating the pricing.
So you're not left guessing.
We really tell you
explicitly, as much as we can,
about what to
expect on your bill.
You can choose a
variety of boot disk.
If you want SSD, or
regular persistent disk.
And when you're done
configuring-- and again,
most of the time you don't need
to tweak any of these options.
You can just go
straight to deploy.
You would hit deploy.
And so this is going to go
take you now to the Deployment
Manager, and this is going
to go into our data centers
and bring up this
WordPress instance.
This might take a minute or so.
So what I've done just
before we came up on stage,
I had actually deployed
another WordPress instance.
I'm going to show you what
that experience looks like.
So here we are.
Our WordPress is deployed.
And our focus here is to
make sure that you can get up
and running as
quickly as possible.
So we show you the IP
address of the VM instance.
It's up and running.
We even show you the URL
for the Admin console.
So you can immediately log
in and start configuring
your WordPress instance.
We've generated a
temporary password, which
you'll change once you log in.
And again, but down here we
still have all of that getting
started guide, the
documentation, et cetera.
One of the nice things about
GCP is our SSH support.
So we have built in
SSH just off the web.
You don't need to
fire up a console.
configure keys.
It's all built in.
And all of our Cloud Launcher
package software VM solutions
have this functionality
built in as well.
So just as a proof to make sure
you're not being tricked here,
this blog is up
and running live.
And just as a proof for
that you can see here.
And I configured it to say this.
So really just a matter
of minutes, you can get up
and running with a blog.
Really straightforward.
So that's a pretty
straightforward application
of Cloud Launcher.
But now let's think about
something a little bit more
sophisticated.
So before I came to Google, I
had run a couple of startups,
and we were heavy
users in MongoDB.
And I would tell you
that we spent, God knows,
how many hours configuring
MongoDB even in the Cloud.
Because we had a
set of replica sets.
We needed multi
zone configuration,
and it was quite a challenge.
So I'm going to show you
how you can deploy MongoDB
at scale, quite easily
through the Cloud Launcher.
So first thing
we're going to do is
we're going to search for Mongo.
And in this case, I'm going
to choose the multi VM
version that we have through
Google Click to Deploy.
Again, same details apply.
In this case, it's
telling me a lot
about the pricing, because
we have multiple VMs
in this configuration.
Including the sustained use
discount, which is quite hefty.
And so once I decide I like
this, I get to this nice UI.
And this time you see different
options for my WordPress.
This time I can set up exactly
the number of nodes I need.
So we have, again,
intelligent defaults.
We start with a
two-node cluster.
But you might want
more, depending
on your configuration.
You can change the machine
type for each node.
We've preconfigured
it to be four
VCPU's and 26 Gigs of memory.
You can change the
disk, and, of course,
you can change the
size of the disk.
And if you've installed MongoDB
before, you know it's not just
about the nodes that
are powering MongoDB,
you also need an additional node
to scale, called an arbiter.
But the arbiter
isn't doing much.
It's just there in
case any of the nodes
go down so it can do
master re-election.
So we've programmed
that intelligent default
into the solution.
And you see it here.
Where we have an
arbiter, and if you
look at the machine
type for the arbiter,
it's one of the smallest
machines we have.
Again, because it's not
doing a whole lot of work.
It doesn't need a lot of memory.
Certainly doesn't
need a lot of CPU.
And so these are
just some of the ways
where we've looked at a problem,
created an architecture,
built intelligent
defaults, and allow
you to deploy with all of that
knowledge just in a few clicks.
So I'll go ahead
and click Deploy.
Similar to last time I've
done this before this talk.
So I'll show you what
that post-deploy screen
looks like for MongoDB here.
It's this one here.
Again, similar to our
WordPress example,
but some different
options this time.
Right?
Here we're talking
about, how you can
connect to the MongoDB primary?
Link you to documentation
and support.
So we've seen simple
configurations,
like a WordPress.
We've seen a multi VM
configuration, like Mongo.
But let's say you're
using this MongoDB,
and it's a couple of months
after you deployed it
from the Launcher.
And you say, great.
This is working well.
I've deployed it in one zone.
I now need to deploy
in yet another zone.
So how would you do that?
Well, now what I'm
going to show you
is how you can use Deployment
Manager to actually redeploy
the same Mongo solution
into a different zone,
with maybe different settings.
So what I've done is,
in this deployment,
I've copied over the
Deployment Manager scripts.
And they're all listed here.
I'm just going to
show you my terminal.
So I've downloaded them here.
And it's just a few files.
And I'm going to open up
the configuration file.
And we're going to do this live.
And so this is a
configuration file that's
Deployment Manager Template.
And the part I want you
to focus on is down here.
And these are basically
parameters that we
can set to configure
this Mongo solution.
Now if you're paying
attention, you
might realize that a
lot of these parameters
are the ones that you saw
in our user experience.
And that's exactly
what's going on.
Our user experience is really
driving these Deployment
Manager templates
behind the scenes.
And so now, we're
going under the hood.
And we're actually opening
up that Deployment Manager
Template.
And instead of deploying
this MongoDB in the zone US
central one F, which is what
we had before, we are actually
can deploy it in US Central 1A.
I cam change other parameters.
For example, the
number of replicas
or the size of a machine.
But in this case, I'm happy
with just changing the zone.
So I'm going to hit Save.
And what I'm going to do now
is jump to the command line.
And using the G Cloud command
line for deploy manager, all
I'm doing is just
specifying this
file-- this MongoDB
dot Yaml-- and I'm
telling G Cloud deploy manager,
create a new deployment.
Call it Mongo Prod Next.
And here's a Config file.
So I'm going to go
ahead and fire that up.
And what this is going to
do is go behind the scenes,
go into our data center, bring
up a cluster of three nodes,
set up MongoDB, configure
all the SSH keys.
Making sure that each node
understands the IP addresses
of all the other nodes.
Set up the arbiter.
All that stuff which
would typically
take you several hours
or sometimes even days.
If you get it right
the first time.
And it's doing this
all behind the scenes.
And it's going to deploy
now in a different zone.
And so this might take me
another 30 seconds or a minute
to finish up.
But, in the meantime, we'll
go back to our UI here.
Here we go.
Actually it's done.
So here we go.
It's the deploy
manager telling us
that it's done
running its script.
And those instances are now up
and running, and we can use it.
So, as you can see, the
power of Deployment Manager
is you can embed this directly
in your CICD pipeline.
It's not just for
kicking the tires.
You can actually run these
solutions in production.
So let's wrap up
some of this demo.
Other couple of points
I want to tell you about
is, sometimes these solutions
take a while to deploy.
And you might be impatient.
If you're like me, want
to get other things done.
So we've done a few things.
One is whenever you deploy
one of these solutions,
we actually send you
an email notification.
And we'll let you know that
your deployment is ready.
And it's not just
a notification,
we actually again connect
you to documentation.
Our goal here is to
make sure that whenever
you choose a piece of software,
and you want to get it up
and running, you have
everything you need
to be successful in doing so.
And this is just
another example of that.
Last but not least,
I want to show you
what it looks like to
purchase SaaS solutions.
So let's say you are
building your application.
You've got your
Mongo up and running.
You've got your app server.
And now you need to send
e-mails to your customers.
So might come in here.
You might use our
global search bar.
You might type an email.
And you see Sun Grid.
And so, this time, we're not
deploying any virtual machines.
This is a SaaS offering.
But this is going
to have a billing
integration with Google.
So you just come down here.
You get to see all the
different plans they have.
And once you are happy with
it, you can click Subscribe.
And this shows up again
on your Google bill.
And beyond that, we
have all the tutorials,
references for the API's in
different languages all built
in.
And you can be up and
running in no time.
Let's switch back to the slides.
So just to recap, between
Orbitera Test Drives and Cloud
Launcher.
Orbitera Test Drives-- great
way to try solutions at no cost.
You don't have to worry
about free trial credits.
You can work directly with
the ISV to learn more.
Cloud Launcher is a great
way to get started on GCP.
Also run things in production.
We're really trying to make it
our one-stop shop for products
and services in GCP.
We've added hundreds
of solutions
over the last couple of years.
And we're adding
them at a record pace
actually, going forward.
So, highly suggest
you check it out
if you haven't seen it before.
Or if you're are
an existing user,
take a look at all the
inventory we've added.